hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the Julius bird generation cup the
first game just ended and it is an
absolute Masterpiece you guys will love
this one yeah if you are just joining in
uh both of them had to defeat a lot of
players to get to the finals uh this is
uh This Is The Knockout brackets in the
semi-finals Magnus defeated Vincent
kymer and Arjun erikaisy defeated kuang
Liam Lei and now they meet in the finals
and this is just uh I mean the game is
breathtaking you you guys will enjoy it
let's dive straight into it uh even
though it's a rapid game there is quite
a lot to enjoy so Magnus with the white
pieces opens with Knight to F3 he goes
for a direct opening D5 by our June G3
and now Pawn to G6 the double theme
Chito of the king's Indian attack with
Bishop G2 Bishop G7 and Magnus castles
we have Knight to F6 going for that
quick castle and now Pawn to D4 by
Magnus we have castles and now uh we
have pawned the C3 Here pawn to C4 is
the standard way to play this Magnus
chooses this line that isn't all that
popular he goes C3 sort of a nice way to
try and surprise Arjun and that June
plays A5 making it a bit difficult for
Magnus to expand on the queen side as
much as he would want to and now Bishop
to F4 putting pressure on that E5 Square
so at some point you know that the
Knight is coming to E5 and here there
are a couple of games that reach this
position for example uh Bishop to F5 was
played here it's a well-known game
between kramnik and maximbashiela grab
that ended in a draw but here we have C6
strengthening the D5 pawn and now uh
Knight beta D2 is a non move but here
Magnus plays Queen to C1 and it is now
already as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game so very interesting
chess being played here in the Holy
Spirit generation cup in the last two
games that we've covered it was already
a completely new game on move nine now
it's in move eight uh I mean what more
could we ask for so here Bishop to G4 as
the queen moved it makes sense to put
pressure on the Knight here Knight beat
the D2 and now Knight beta D7 we have H3
challenging the bishop and here just the
bishop capture so Arjun giving up the
bishop pair early on but he has put his
pawns on lights whereas the dark Square
Bishop is nicely
um yeah helping out with the defense of
the black king and at some point you
will try to make use of it maybe a nice
uh C5 breakthrough or E5 all depending
on what Magnus plays so Rook E8
preparing that E5 push it's not easy
because the E5 square is controlled
three times so you would have to do
something like move the Knight for the
bishop to control E5 as well C4 by
Magnus and now Queen to B6 uh putting
pressure on that D4 Pawn so Rook to D1
and now Knight to E4 we have Bishop to
E3 now you could also play E3 but uh
Magnus decides to defend the the pawn
with Bishop to E3 is not that the Knight
moved the bishop and queen are attacking
this pawn and now Queen to A6 Arjun says
that Magnus needs the uh well uh decide
what to do with the pawn do you want to
capture or do you want to advance it to
C5 or do you wanna at some point play
Maybe B3 so Magnus says I'm not doing
any of that right away first night the
E5 it's just a very annoying move
whenever that Knight lands and E5 you
just know that uh you can never capture
it otherwise you'll just be worth it
it's just known you know if you're a
chess player uh here like if you capture
here D captures uh what do you play for
example Rook a to d8 you put the the
rook and the D file C captures C
captures let's say Bishop captures I
need for D captures Rook capture 78 Rook
captures and now for example Queen to C7
white is the one that will be putting
pressure on this position so instead
after Knight E5 we have Knight D to F6
and now Magnus plays Queen to C2 he
again puts pressure on the uh on the E4
Knight making D captures and C for an
impossible move as then just Bishop
captures and E4 wins a piece so Knights
the D6 now putting more pressure on that
C4 pawn and Magnus pushes it to C5 like
I said you could consider B3 but then
you just give Arjun a move that he
really wants to play into this now is is
a with Tempo so here C5 challenging the
Knight Knight the B5 you could also put
it on F5 it's a very nice Square for the
night but Arjun decides to go to B5 and
now Magnus plays Ponte F4 and now with
the spawn to F for push magnet shows
that he is now ready to start pushing on
the king side uh otherwise he could also
play a move like a for this Lodge this
Knight for example Knight to see it and
play Rook to B1 with the idea of busting
open the B file as now B4 is an actual
possibility and then you will just put
pressure on the backwards B7 Pawn so
okay after Knight B5 Magnus decides to
go for the king side attack instead he
plays F4 a for now by Arjun saying uh B4
will not be played this game and now
Pawn to G4 and the magnets took quite a
lot of time uh Arjun was playing pretty
much all of his moves instantly he did
uh spend time on a few of them but
Magnus is down already to some 8 minutes
and Arjun has well over 11 minutes
uh A3 of course G5 is a thread but Arjun
makes Magnus uh decide what to do here
on the queen side before uh you know
deciding whether he wants to push upon
move the Knight or what uh and now
Magnus plays Pawn to B3 and this is uh
the way to go if you push Pawn to B4 uh
basically uh crosson's idea is that he
wants to push pawns on the king side and
he needs to keep control over the E4
Square as long as he does that the
Knight doesn't have access to E4 he's
gonna be fine but now if you push Pawn
to B4 which is almost always a good idea
Queen A4 offers a queen trade then if
you move the queen you allow Knight to
E4 and it's not uh what you want to do
so B3 is the way to go uh Rook 838 by
Arjun and now Rook 8 to C1 now even
making Queen A5 uh pointless because now
the C3 square is nicely guarded so you
you are never giving up control over D4
Square so Knights the D7 and Arjun says
all right I can't win more space so
maybe I can trade down which is a good
idea you know if you're opponent
controlling more space you should always
trade down but now Magnus plays Bishop
to F2 and here it seems like he's
preparing this Pawn push to E4 and he
wants to bust open the center but after
arjun's Pawn to E6 Magnus plays uh
something incredible now you should you
should not play this
um I hear you a good idea would be G5 as
capturing here isn't that great captors
captures you open up the file for the
white Rooks uh the pawns here with
Incredible control over the over the F6
square and even if you don't do that
after G5 the Knight can come to G4 and
now you you will have Knight F6 Knight
H6 in the future so it's very nice what
I was super amazed here is that when I
saw this position as I was watching it
live I was like what about Bishop to H4
this seems like a great move as it
attacks The Rook um and then I checked
the the engine I checked the top three
or four evaluations and none of them
were best of stage four so I was like
okay I mean my suggestion is uh not all
that great but then Magnus played Bishop
H4 and I was like what both Magnus and I
played the move that the engine did not
recommend obviously it's a strong move
but uh it it turns out that it's not
it's actually a blunder but it's not
easy to take advantage of this blunder
and unless you know it's a blunder so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to take advantage of this uh in
Precision maybe not a blunder but an
imprecision while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's Pawn to
G5 that's that's the move I mean I know
incredible for one if you play F
characters then you weaken the Knight
then black can start capturing on E5 and
you really have nothing to worry about
if Bishop captures on G5 then of course
you play F6 and now you attack the
bishop and the Knight and there's really
no good way to handle this if you
capture the Knight on D7 then just F
cappers and G5 your knight is hanging
now and once you move the Knight back G
captures and F4 and black solved all of
his problems now black will be the one
controlling the f file and you have a
very nice Pawn on F4 so the the D4 Pawn
is weak now it's just an incredible
position and after G5 if you don't
capture if you play Bishop to G3 not all
that different just captures captures
and now the spectacular Knight captures
and the for weakening the Knight on E5
and after Rook captures just the bishop
captures here on E5 Bishop characters
Knight captures and blacks filled all of
his problems so really congratulations
to everyone who found that but it would
seem Arjun did not uh think about the
possibility of Magnus actually missing
this and he plays F6 uh probably If he
if he was playing against anyone else
other than Magnus he would uh allow for
the possibility that Magnus made a
mistake but I I think this was the case
in this game so Knight back to F3 and
now we have Knight to f um eight also to
be considered as B6 just trying to bust
open the this structure on the on the
queen side and put pressure on the
center but he plays Knight to f8 he
doesn't want to allow Magnus to put put
pressure on on the king side and now
Ponte E3 uh we have Queen to A5 trying
to get the queen into the game somehow
maybe even via the C7 Square now Bishop
to F1 preparing Bishop to D3 we have
Knight the C7 and now Magnus advances
the pawn to G5 with knights the 7
defending the df6 square G captures an
F6 Bishop captures and now Magnus uh
captures on F6 although to be considered
is definitely Pawn to B4 uh just winning
more more space on the queen side that's
always useful and of course if Queen
captures Rook B1 followed by Rook
characters on B7 so you would push the
black queen back to a silly Square
because the Knight is still on C7 and
queen to C7 is impossible so always keep
in mind the possibility of Pawn to B4
but okay Magnus plays Bishop captures on
F6 Knight captures and now Bishop to D3
with the threat of Bishop captress and
G6 captures captures with the queen then
Knight comes to G5 uh black will fall
apart here so Rook the E7 adding another
Defender here you want to be ready with
Rook to G7 now King the H2 and look at
what Magnus has created here uh Arjun
can't really use the Rooks well the
Knight does not have a good Square this
Knight is on a good square but it's not
really doing all that much and Queen on
A5 completely use list and now look at
all this pressure Magnus is able to put
on the G6 Square the queen attacks it
the bishop attacks it the Rooks will be
doubled on the G file both of the Rooks
will be attacking it and the Knight is
coming to E5 most likely adding more
pressure to the G6 Pawn so you can be
sure that you are not going to be able
to defend G6 but of course Arjun has to
try he plays Rook f8
uh Rook to G1 by Magnus Knight C to E8
now
preparing The Rook to come to G7 the
Knight Will nicely be defending it there
Rook to G2 just doubling up here we have
Knight to G7 and here Magnus played Rook
seat the G1 and I think Magnus here was
uh just trying to create the perfect
position as of course he knows he he
can't really lose this uh he didn't
spend time to check this but Bishop
captures and G6 can also be played here
for example captures captures and now
it's uh I mean how do you play this if
let's say Knight Knight H7 just Rook G1
and if let's say Rook to F5 whatever you
play a queen H6 threatening Rook capture
series Queen to c795 so it's a it's a
similar position that Magnus is going
for uh but he could have went for the
went for the sacrifice right away then
the Knight comes the G6 and you are
without any move so okay a Magnus
continues with Rook C to G1 he did make
that one chessable course attacking
without sacrificing so maybe he's just
you know promoting it
Queen to C7 now and this is the move
that really allows Magnus to break
through here with Knight to F5 you would
have you would have Magnus um definitely
working for his meal he would have to
give up the bishop and after he captures
yes he he can win a pawn uh but maybe
you can still defend let's say Knight to
the E8 and now okay uh let's say queen
to C2 Rook to F6 you are done material
but you are still in the game after the
move that Arjun played the queen to C7
uh now it no longer is possible now
Magnus plays Bishop captures and G6 H
captures Queen captures uh and now
Knight to E4 uh useful Square for the
Knight preventing Knight to the G5 and
now everyone was expecting Knight the E5
but Magnus played Knight to the G5 just
for the fun of it I will show Knight the
E5 because it's it's beautiful point is
that after a few moves The Rook attacks
the queen for example Rook F6 Queen H5
Rook F5 Queen H6 and Rook F6 you play
Rook G6 and after captures you will
capture with the Knight and now queen h8
queen to faith is Unstoppable for
example if you can get F7 you still play
it and after Rook d8 attacking the queen
uh the spectacular Knight of Fate now
you are threatening Queen capture Sun G7
and there's no way to deal with this if
Knight F5 just Queen H7 check King
captures and f8 and Rook to G8 is
Checkmate just an example of how strong
the the attacking potential is but
Magnus goes for a different line he
plays Knight G5 Knight captures Rook
captures and now we have Rook the F5
Arjun wants to trade off as many
attackers as possible again just for the
fun of it I will show the line Rook
captures on F4 trying to give up a rook
for some sort of a Perpetual it doesn't
work because just Queen G7 and that's it
Rook captures Queen captures Queen
captures Rook captures King captures and
now after this brutal capture Fest uh
you just have a completely winning King
and pawn end game so you you have to
keep that in mind as well so Rook F5 and
now Magnus just goes one square back
Rook five to G4 interestingly even in
this position Rook Rook to G4 is the
only winning move uh Rook e to F7 and
now Magnus plays uh Queen captures an E6
and he was in this position unmove 40
that Arjun erigasi resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the threat of course is Rook captures on
G7 The Rook on F7 is pinned and there is
no way to survive this if you move the
king king to f8 uh just a nice root
captures on G7 and now you have to
remove the defender of The Rook on F5
that's that's the uh you know the the
the the tool behind the position Queen
captures an F5 check and if you defend
uh okay you still have a queen and the
Rook but it's a very easy to win this
for example Queen G5 and now after King
the E8 you just play uh Queen H5 uh and
the King can never move away from the
defense of the rook and it doesn't
really matter what you try Queen E7 just
Rook G7 attacks the pinned piece and you
trade down once again into a winning
King and pawn end game let's say queen
f8 you're just gonna trade everything
off in the king and opponent game is
winning for Magnus so uh definitely a
spectacular Masterpiece uh Magnus did
allow Arjun uh to really take control of
the position with this bishop H4 move uh
I mean can you imagine my disappointment
I I thought about the move and I checked
the engine and it was like nah that's
silly move and then Magnus plays it and
I was super happy you know as I I guess
a move that Magnus would play and that
it's not one of the engine moves but it
was actually a big mistake but both like
Magnus and Arjun
have missed it I didn't miss it because
I didn't think about the position all
that much but I would never find this of
course uh but yeah after missing this it
was uh all Magnus and now Magnus is
leading the match by one full point but
there are still three more games to
bounce back we'll see what happens stay
tuned as I will inform you of what has
happened uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it like a beautiful
beautiful uh attacking game by Magnus uh
this was just I mean
the when you saw that Magnus played this
Rook the G2 move and then understood
that the Knight is coming here and the
Rooks are gonna get doubled and then G6
Square will just be uh you know
impossible to defend you knew that this
cannot end well for for Arjun but yeah
he did have a chance he didn't take it
and that's obviously uh more than enough
for Magnus to take a full point uh so uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and have learned a lot from it I would
like to thank Stuart Matthews Derek King
Brian parking golden pawn and mebdishuki
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the finals uh until it ends
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day